كقطعه من قطع الدومينو تهاوى هذا المجمع
السكني الشهير في محافظه هاتاي جراء
الزلزال مئات العائلات كانت تقطن في هذا
المجمع الضخم الذي اشتهر بعد اعتقال
الشرطه في مطار اسطنبول المتعهد الذي بناه
تجمع عينات من هيكل البناء المتناثر لعلها
تفيد التحقيقات في شبهه الغش في مواد
البناء
كثيرون فارقوا الحياه هنا يمر الوقت ثقيلا
على من نجى من الفاجعه
علاء وادهم مهندسان اخواني جاء الى تركيا
بعد انقطاع التواصل مع اقارب لهما كانوا
يعيشون هنا
يشتكي الاخوان قله عدد الفرق الاحترافيه
ويرابطان هنا خشيه ان تخرج جثه ما دون
القاء نظره عليها للتاكد من هويه صاحبها
اي مساعده ما في اي تنظيم نحن جاهزين انه
نساعد وكل الناس موجودين جاهزين انه
يساعدوا وانا بشهد انه الفرق الموجوده
قادرين على هذا الشيء لكن للاسف ما في
تنظيم وهذا هو الجرح اللي نحن عم ننجرحه
كل يوم انه لو في تنظيم للعمل نحن قادرين
انه نطلع جثث اكثر من من 500 شخص موجود
غير بعيدا عن المجمع يعيش في هذه الخيمه
ما بقي من عائله كان عددها كبيره
قاسيه هي الحياه اليوميه في الخيام يزيدها
حده نقص الخدمات في مثل هذه الظروف
عن يارا جانب لا نعرف ما الذي سيحصل غدا
خرجنا بلا شيء لا توجد مشكله في الطعام
فهو يصلنا لكن نحتاج الى خدمات كدورات
المياه والاضاءه ليلا لو حل هذا الامر
يمكن ان نتدبر امرنا بضعه اشهر
تتواصل اعمال رفع الالقاب وازاله الركام
الى ان يتم التاكد تماما من عدم وجود ناجا
او جثه ترقد تحت وسطتها تعد هاتاي واحده
من اكثر المحافظات تضررا بالزلزال مع اكثر
من 2000 مبنى تحول الى كومه من الركام ولا
يختلف حالها عن حال محافظات اخرى شرد فيها
الناس وهامه على وجوههم او هلكوا تحت
الانقاض
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره